[Musique]
commençons par l'inquiétude elle grandit
chaque jour face à l'évolution de
l'épidémie le taux d'incidence a franchi
la barre des 300 pour la première fois
depuis mi-avril que de 47 mille nouveaux
cas de kovy détecter ces dernières 24
heures en france c'est un niveau qui
n'avait jamais été observée depuis la
troisième vague information exclusive
issue de la conférence des ministres
président l'allemagne se dirige vers une
obligation générale de vaccination
l'autriche a déjà pris une telle mesure
mais si cela se confirme et en allemagne
ce serait un coup de tonnerre qui
pourrait avoir des répercussions sur les
autres pays européens
l'obligation vaccinale n'est pas le
choix que la france a fait qui dit
obligation qui contrôle et sanction donc
la faisabilité n'est pas n'est pas
évidente nous avons une couverture
vaccinale beaucoup plus importante que
les pays qui aujourd'hui s'interrogent
et qui pensent aller vers une obligation
vaccinale il faut rester sur la ligne
convaincre plutôt que contraindre il est
approprié et raisonnable d'avoir cette
discussion maintenant une discussion sur
la manière dont on peut encourager et
potentiellement réfléchir à la
vaccination obligatoire je suis à me
faire piquer cet après-midi pour tout
vous dire 15 heures la troisième dose
d'effets secondaires passe au stade sauf
si je me mets à radoter vous allez vous
saurez comment ça qu on s'étreint [ __ ]
ça sera pas dit avec sa
merci je suis très frustré qu'inquiet
zemmour avant pourquoi il veut vous
descendre savez tous les chrétiens
fascistes
et depuis qu'elle est moore on sait plus
insulter
c'était une interview d'un procureur
puig menace de mauvaise foi me sortant
des phrases de mon livre hors de leur
contexte un bref je vous remercie de
faire encore preuve de mépris et
d'arrogance comme vous le faites si
souvent rien à mes choix vous les petits
mouchoirs il va pleurer non il va
pleurer après qui sait pas ce que je
vous ai fait beau j'ai envie de dire à
celles et ceux qui auraient été pris de
saisie d'effroi en regardant ce clip bon
ouvrez les fenêtres respirer mais
ternaire de musique peut-être un peu
plus léger la france de monsieur zemmour
n'existe pas on peut considérer qu'il
est curieux
que dans un clip de lancement d'une
campagne présidentielle une personne un
candidats choisissent de jeter à la
vindicte des noms des portrait parce que
c'est ça qui fait j'aime pas taper sur
sur les gens qui sont à terre déjà il
est déjà à terre pour vous il ya un
moment très difficile pour lui oui cet
homme qui était un journaliste avec qui
j'étais en désaccord absolue
c'est un rôle le représentant le plus le
plus radicale de l'extrême droite et qui
est en train d'exploser en vol il fait
son clip vidéo son annonce avec la la
componction après là et en même temps à
marseille il fait des doigts d'honneur
le sujet aujourd'hui c'est pas une
candidature dix fois annoncé 10 x 10
qualifiés de quelqu'un qui confond de
gaulle et pétain monsieur boulot a voulu
faire le malin devant ses confrères
monsieur boulot anna n'a pas fait son
boulot monsieur boulot n'a pas fait son
boulot c'est toujours mieux que
l'insultent connards qui l'aurait
ensuite lâché dans les couloirs de tf1
selon plusieurs témoins en sortant du
plateau il aurait hurlé c'est un connard
un vrai connard le connaissant il est
pas complètement improbable qu'il ait
dit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sébastien alvarez a réalisé un saut
exceptionnel il a plongé en fait dans
l'un des volcans les plus actifs du chic
le villa rica le cascadeur vous avez vu
à sauter d'un hélicoptère avant de se
diriger à plus de 200 kilomètres heure
vers le cratère du volcan qui est actif
à la plongée dedans
[Musique]